and it will be given by don't leave we
will talk about quantum algorithms on
thank you how would your first thanks
for the igniters for you inviting me to
give the talk here today I'm going to
merely talk about quantum algorithms on
comics bodies so what is the motivation
for this topic I think the previous two
talks by retrial and Anupam they have
been talking about fast quantum
algorithms for assuming SDP a clone
programming etc I think with explicit
matrices during quantum data structure
so this is really some power that
basically we have the data structure and
there's something microscopic but I
think another question to us is to see
this problem more macroscopic later for
instance what if you don't have the
explicit matrix input but maybe only
some implicit Oracle access what can we
do with characterization and what is the
corresponding quantum speed-up so what
do I mean by implicit oracle access so
in particular for instance like
important collectivization problems like
the LP like the SDP and many others I
mean we talked about convex combination
problem they have convex feasible region
collects what okay that is in an
n-dimensional real space so a common
Oracle access to talk about a certain
comic spot is the membership Oracle
where you assume that ability to to test
whether point in the in the regions
inside a Comics body or not so it's
basically a function the membership
function that returns 1 if your point
inside the comics body where it equals
to 0 if point is outside the comics body
the main topic today is going to talk
about what can we do only on comics body
we stress like this very general
information about the comics body but
with the membership Oracle only with the
X kind of quantum stories Asian access
that is basically do you say a quantum
unitary Oracle that map's the quantum
said X 0 to the common state acts are
monkey acts where the monkey acts as a
boolean value that equals to 1 if your
ax is inside a comics body or equals to
0 it's not so this is really like a very
general problem in a very general
definition about about a certain problem
set so speaking above a bada Comics body
what is probably the for the first
question that maybe you want to ask
maybe the very first question is that
giving a quacks body you want to you for
instance at estimate this volume which
is going to be defined as the integral
of the identity function on this convex
set
so to be more specific for the volume
estimation problem we also have a
certain input epsilon which is the error
and we are both are basically going to
return the value that s between 1 minus
epsilon times the volume and 1 plus
epsilon times the volume with high
success probability what we want to
study this problem I think this is
specifically at the very beginning about
the most natural problem that if you
want to play with a very general
characterization and also are speaking
of the the merit of the problem per se
it is really one of the most basic
problems in geometry and also when
talking about this connection yes
measure used by can you comment on the
measure the measure of what yes yes it's
just like a integral roundest a real
space so just like a connects body what
is the confusion yes yes so the key here
is a coax body is really like a
continuous comic cell
well it's like the number of things is
uncountable because it's just it should
be an integral here sorry yeah this is
really we're talking about the K here is
a continuous set yeah you have to like
define it as an integral of them of the
corresponding region yes you submit a
vector X in RN and it tells you whether
it's inside the body or outside but this
is like a vector of real numbers to me
what should I think of like it's just
all the entries being big like there's a
possible precision yes yes so you can
just imagine the X here to be
represented as floating numbers and for
floating numbers I think they just maybe
have a 64 bit something like that and
there can be some error error inside
here but I think also on the other hand
I think our Oracle is is robust to the
error that if you have some slightly
error dependence does not influence the
problem by much no no it's finite
yeah I think later on I will be more
careful about how we are going to
characterize the problem
and other questions
okay so I think on the one hand this
problem is very natural because it is
wealth the most basic problems in
geometry and also on the other hand
speaking of the connection to quantum
computing I think this can be real as a
continuous version of counting and I
think quantum country in general has
been widely applied to our Tagawa type
algorithms and if you have a good
understanding about the volume
estimation problem we may also consider
some a continuous counterpart of our
many other quantum algorithms I think we
want you to be a little bit more clear
about like how we are going to formulate
a problem so you are clear as a
destination the input model is going to
be this kind of quantum Oracle and I
think there are some other are
regularization constraint for the
problem so for instance we assume the
original point inside the convex body so
this is just to make sure that for
instance if the comic spot is it's not
on the earth than we probably cannot
give a good quantum algorithm for that
so you just assume the original point
inside the convex body and also we
assume some some some sort of
information like a condition number of
the corresponding comics body we will
assume that comic spot is contained you
are really large bovis radius capital R
and contains a corresponding small ball
with radius small R where this the
beach.you dress represents the
corresponding boy in the sense of l
2-norm
so classically the best known classical
query complexity for swimming the volume
estimation problem given this kind of
assumption where the original point
inside the convex body and also some
sort of condition number the capital
aren't small here the classical best to
inquire complexity is only into the for
a Bella wash and wahala in 2003 and
actually this is although there's like
well the most important problem this
problem is known to be notoriously hard
and you see like this classical
complexity of n to the 4 has been
standing for more than 15 years so very
recently we gave a quantum algorithm
that can surf the volume estimation
problem using only n to the 3 plus + to
the 2.5 over epsilon quantum queries for
the quantum queries to the corresponding
membership Oracle's where that should
all here armies of holland algorithmic
factors so in particular it on it only
like the dependence on the condition
number the capital ro s Mar is only poly
log and also some of it autos contains
some other terms like log in and log man
over Epsilon
so how do we compare this to classical
state of the arts like the classical
best known algorithm has a
transmission like due to large anjala
has into the four complexity and I think
it can be slightly polished down your
later work due to constant Salem Heller
and the total complexity can be likened
to the four plus into the 300 epsilon
squared whereas our quantum complexity
you see like it's both bettering and
also like the epsilon dependence has
struck quadratically better and speaking
of the total arithmetic complexity like
both the quantum and classical algorithm
is blow up by a factor of N squared so
it's that classical it is this but
quantum is this so after all I think we
have posed quantum speed-up for the
complexity and arithmetic complexity of
the world in estimation problem yes yes
yes yes the classical best-known lower
bound is due to rhythm acronym and holla
wishes and to the intruder to over log n
roughly N squared yes
ultimately we have a squirt of N quantum
lower bound which is probably far from
tight but hopefully we can later improve
it but but I think at least our quantum
lower bound give us a conceptual message
for this very general case like you had
like a very general characterization
problem and a membership Oracle
especially about the volume estimation
problem the quantum speed-up can be at
most polynomial okay so let's delve more
into the problem now so speaking about a
volume estimation problem what is the
first thing that you can probably think
about maybe on top of your head may be
like a very naive algorithm is dressed
like a Monte Carlo approach which says
you do the counting brute-force ly
something like this but actually it
doesn't work very well because the
volume actually takes an exponentially
large range because for instance if it's
only no one should be containing a large
bow of radius capital R to the end of
radius capital R then the volume can be
roughly speaking at as large as capital
R to the N as small as smart to the end
this is really like it's financial a
large range I probably just like a
brute-force counting argument which
exponential cause and doesn't work well
in practice so instead what what is the
strategy that well we are going to use
here so maybe we want to consider some
parameter as value like this so what is
the motivation for considering this kind
of like our partition function I think
on the one hand it has the
the nature that the the the the z0
valuable to because to the volume of the
comics body but also on the other hand
if you check to another extreme because
the exponential function takes things
actually decays exponentially fast with
rack to the l2 norm of the of the value
of the x here if you choose a large
enough a here it will ensure that the
value of z is going to be close to close
enough to a fixed value which you don't
have to really take the whole integral
on the convex body but it suffices that
you only take the integral on the small
one because like otherwise like the the
outside part a real attic has to fast
and this is actually a good estimation
of the value here so i think this is
really going to motivate us and in
particular i think this actually
corresponds to two that simulated
annealing strategy where maybe we want
to consider sequences or a sequence of
values on from a 0 to a 1 2 a.m. where
the a0 here is sufficiently large but
finally the a.m. here is going to be
small enough and it is actually going to
be very close to 0 and we are totally
change the values the from AI to AI plus
1 and we estimate the volume of the
comics body but a telescoping product
like this okay so this is really going
to give the motivation because on the
one hand we there on the left hand side
this is something we want and at the
very beginning and there is something we
know but on the other hand how we want
to estimate each telescoping ratio we
are going to for each telescope in ratio
take some ID samples inside the convex
body and we are going to take the
average so what do i mean by that so in
particular if you are given the ability
to sample from the corresponding density
like this e to the minus a attempts the
l2 norm of the value of x if you denote
this random variable that you know
output has random variable X I and will
correspond latino Tyranno a random
variable VI like this then the
expectation of this random variable if
you take the corresponding integral and
just make a calculation it is just going
to be a telescoping product that you
want so the initial problem here becomes
like we don't really we actually make a
reduction from the estimation of each
telescope in ratio to give a good random
walk that is really going to sample from
the corresponding density like this and
how we are going to do this
I think in the in the Loess mm hell a
paper they actually use a specific kind
of random walk inside the comics body
called a hit and run walk and actually
it constitutes two steps so where for
the first step you are going to you for
instance assume you are currently at a
point p1 here you are going to pick a
unit from the random line l through the
current point P here so for instance if
you just draw very small Saphir here
you're just like a pickle random point
on the Saffir maybe at this point you're
just like should this corresponding
court here and for the second point
after you should the court which is
going to intersect with the
corresponding convex body you are going
to move to a random point along this
court and with the car which is going to
be proportional to this density so what
is the main argument and what is the
main observation here
so in general walking in n dimensional
space is a very difficult task in
general suffers from the curse of
dimensionality but this gives a very
natural reduction from n dimensional
walk to a one-dimensional walk and
actually works very well and in
particular in the Loess of Impella paper
it actually follows this simulated
annealing strategy where the simulated
annealing algorithm in total is going to
have squared off in a durations and
inside each iteration they are going to
they're going to take squared of n or
epsilon square iid samples such that you
are going to give a good precision of
the estimation of the telescoping ratio
and for each sample basically on each
sample come out of the heat and run walk
actually it is going to take about cubic
step of the hit and run walk given a
promise that your comics body is well
rounded but well round I mean the
condition number is at most square root
of n so why do we really like stick with
the value of square root of n because
this really naturally appears in a lot
of comics bodies in the N dimensional
space in particular if you think about
like a unit hypercube it just has the
condition number to be squared of n and
if you consider like a sphere the
corresponding condition number is very
good it's just 1 so at least the lowest
Mahalo for now they give a good
classical algorithm for the volume
estimation problem under the
well-rounded case but also on the other
hand can consider some reduction like
for being well rounded may be for
instance when access is just too long
the other axis is too short but maybe
you can kiss there try to construct some
affine transformation there really for
instance if you have exploit here you
want to punch it you out - a severe here
which is going to be looking very good
and which is actually going to be well
rounded and in fact the Loess on hell
are they give a classical algorithm the
only using into the four classical query
to making such kind of effing
transformation to make the input convex
body well-rounded so in total the
complexity like like Samia through like
the this kind of well-rounded
well-rounded maybe we can read
regardless as a pre-processing step and
also like the corresponding similar
nearly algorithm the total complexity is
going to be n to the 4 over epsilon
squared so let's make a quick summary
here about the success of the classical
volume estimation in algorithm and
actually there are three key factors so
for the first factor it actually high
level is speaking this actually a
similar annealing algorithm where the
volume is going to be estimate by some
by a product of some telescoping ratios
and for the middle level we are going to
take some iid samples such that we can
give a good estimation of each kind of
this kind of telescope in ratio and the
other words I think it is very important
that the the random variable that come
out of the corresponding work is very
small and for the low level we have to
think about some implementation of the
corresponding walk and in particular the
course that the corresponding random
walk converges fast such that we can
really efficiently take 90 samples so
this is basically like the rough story
about a volume estimation algorithm so
how we are going to think about like a
corresponding quantum volume estimation
algorithm maybe you want to question us
from also from the three levels high
level middle level and low level so for
instance at the high level may be a very
natural question to ask is that whether
we can consider like a quantum similar
medium framework for the middle level
here because really we are going to give
estimation about the each telescoping
ratio and this is really something like
some something like I'm here to
estimation and maybe we want to ask us
that whether we can give a quantum
speed-up by quantum counting and for the
for the low level here because like the
classical algorithm for instance the
heat and run/walk there's really
something a very close relationship
reavie asphere ease of quantum walks
maybe you also want to ask whether such
kind of speed up is possible okay so I
think maybe for my talk I'm going to act
like go through like this different
levels separately maybe let's first go
with the low level so as I just
mentioned like for instance there has
something previous about quantum box
especially for instance secondes theory
but I think the main consideration it
has been happening in the discrete space
so how we are going to consider how some
continuous space quantum walks so this
is somehow like we are going to
just like a move move from the discrete
space the continuous way using secretary
theory and furthermore we can actually
show that shickers inequality for the
continuous pace Markov chains and
actually in our paper we gave a very
detailed analysis about how we are going
to relate such kind of like continuously
hit-and-run walk to it's a discrete
highest version and basically we gave a
very good analysis about like how the
conductance is going to change when we
move from the continuous case due to the
corresponding discrete case and actually
what is the result here so if like the
furnace for instance the classical law
was one hell of paper if they show they
can show that their hit-and-run well
converges in cubic time then also on the
other hand we can show that our quantum
heat and run/walk
operators unitary operators that have
spectral gap at least n to the minus 1
point excuse
so this is a very rough understanding
about the low level maybe we also like
on the other hand we want to get
understanding about the high level about
the simulated annealing framework we are
going to in particular utilize a similar
new framework due to Bosnian and we are
seeing he wishes going to talk about
some because this it very naturally
talks about quantum walk operators and
which is the case that we use for our
quantum version of the heat of your walk
we have corresponding quantum walk
operators may be from W 1 to W are you
know similar an alien procedure and
correspondingly they have stationary
States from W 1 2 pi 1 2 pi R and
because this is a similar illness
schedule like the overlap between
consecutive stationary States they
should be large like for instance the
inner product here should be at least P
here we also do not like the Delta to be
the general lower bounds on the spectral
gaps of the quantum walk operators so a
very natural question here is that how
we are going to change from the very
start station or a PI 1 to the final
station is a PI R that we really need
for the for the simulation schedule so
by doing this we are going to in case
there really some amplification kind of
things but we use like an alternate
version which is called fixed point
search and also called PI over 3 MP to
identification very instead of the
normal grover that having like a PI and
go here we only have a PI over 3 and go
here and because there's not kind of PI
were three reflections I smear married
is that it won't have the problem in the
original grower algorithm above over
shooting and actually in general if you
apply this kind of PI over three and
unification a turret iteratively you are
going to get very close to the next step
the next state that you are going to
need so this is actually a very
important building block of our quantum
algorithm as through like the quantum of
selenium strategy we are going to apply
PI were three amp you can amplification
throughout from the very beginning state
high one two by two and finally to the
state PI R that we need for the for the
volume estimation algorithm and also on
the other hand we take the similar nina
schedule slow enough such that the
overlap tip here is a constant and
actually make sure that i'm here like
the number of iterations for the highway
three amplification is only a constant
in saturation and a total complexity for
the aslam framework is going to be R
over R P times Delta where the data
recorder Delta is here the spectral gap
of all the control
operators and P here is the overlap
between consecutive stationary states so
we are quantum algorithm for volume
estimation they are here like the total
iterations for the simulation engine
schedule is going to be squared of n and
as at estimation each each WI here is
going to be the Quantum Conundrum walk
operator and without velocity
proportional to the corresponding
spatial distribution and also on the
other hand we know that PI 0 is easy to
prepare it's just like we just have to
really uh prepare the density on the
small Bob here because the density
reality has to fathom we don't have to
worry about the things outside and also
the spectral gap as a transmission for
the low level part it at least into the
minus 1.5 so in total this really gives
a good simulation schedule that we can
actually implement our quantum algorithm
but the only remaining question here is
that how many stays here do we actually
have to prepare such that overall we can
give a good estimate for each
telescoping ratio by quantum counting
with higher precision and actually reach
the high success probability that we
need so this is really the quantum
counting problemi just a very briefly
recall this so we assume that we have a
unitary you hear that map tested zero
zero to a stay with which half the
amplitude square root of P here and I
think in general compared to the
classical for instance I could turn off
turn off bound the basically quantum we
can actually reach only or epsilon cost
to to give a good estimate about a
probability P here compared to a
classical sampling procedure so in
general here there are some for the
technique developed by our harmonium
McNeil's which is called quantum
chebyshev inequality in january have a
unitary that correspond to a certain
random variable which is going to be a
summation like this then basically this
technique due to harmonium McNeil's that
can also make everything go through
we're actually compared to a class
conversion of the chebyshev in ecology
that dependence on the variance and also
that dependence on the absolute here can
both be given a quantum quadratic
speed-up so using this quantum chemistry
in college and also give the given a
very important observation in the in the
in a volume estimation algorithm
actually the variance here is very small
because the similar eating is slow
enough and such kind of procedure is
called chebyshev Cooley that
we can if we put the corresponding
quantum machine in college into our
framework we can notice that if there
are a squirt of an aerosol square
classical samples for the classical vice
making a classical telescoping ratio and
quantum maybe we only have to use
squirtle over epsilon quantum copies of
the states PI such that we can give a
good estimation of the telescoping ratio
so let's make a summary about the
quantum algorithm here so for the
high-level here we can adapt the quantum
a similar Nerium framework and actually
the total number iterations is square
root of n for the middle level we are
going to replace like a classical
sampling procedure by a quantum tree
bushing all in equality and a total
number cost to the quantum here and
run/walk
operator is going to be squared of an
over Epsilon and for the low level the
number of queries to implement each step
of the quantum walk operator is going to
be in to the 1.5 and also I don't have
time to you to cover here but also we
gave a round the algorithm that really
liked punch a very real condition
collects body to a well-conditioned case
only using cubic number of quantum
queries and you know select the query
contest the quantum complexity of our
algorithm is the N to the 3 plus + to
the 12.5 or epsilon as I claimed at the
very beginning of my talk and speaking
about arithmetic complexity so why the
classical and quantum complexities are
both blow up by a factor of N squared
this is basically because of the around
impart the random part is actually the
FN transformation is an N dimensional
matrix vector product so very naturally
the quantum and classical algorithm
speaking of the total arithmetic
operations like in our quantum cases
into the 5 + n to the 4.5 or episode so
this is specifically the quantum
algorithm for volume estimation is there
any question quantum computers
you discretized it in some fashion yes
yes yes
so I think I in my talk I didn't cover
it very carefully but I need a low you
know low level part I talk about this
quantum heat and run/walk operators so
we have a theory about like basically we
deal with everything in the continuous
space but yeah you must be a specific
section of our paper we also talked
about is correspond discs with highest
version so for instance you only have
great points it's just like imagine you
have like a really really fine green
like great for that for your
corresponding convex body
you can also correspondingly do you find
your hidden rebel on that and I think a
very important thing is that if you if
you consider the corresponding a great
find enough then the corresponding
conductors the lower bound on the
contact conductance of the discrete
highest hidden rock is going to be very
close to the conductance of the of the
original a continuous heat and run/walk
and actually in practice we are just
going to use the discretized version of
the heat on ground walk in putting a
real number you're interested yes yes we
can say that yes so many points do you
have
if in each dimension each dimension does
go then
I think so I kind of forgot that details
yeah but it is not a thing it should
definitely be a polynomial n probably
something just like the
yes
sorry oh yes
so if you're coming if your body is not
connecting like the conductance is you
just totally have no clue for the
conductance for instance maybe your
early marker
yes so the comebacks stay here mainly
appears in the in the in the in the walk
part so for instance you have like a
really bad collects body maybe something
like this then maybe if you just
consider he hung robot like doing this
like doing this doing this doing this I
think maybe at some point you are you
are feeling good because for instance
maybe you get enough information about
this point but like say for instance
maybe this is a sausage and for the most
part of the sausage you just have no
information your work just cannot reach
it and in general is just like for for a
non-convex body is just impossible to
give a like a corresponding walk with a
reasonable conductance we're just going
to be like that
the main issue of the corresponding
algorithm post classically and contantly
and other questions yes for speed up
what is arithmetic operations well
that's a very good question I don't know
actually I think in general for yeah I
guess I'm not sure if like my talk is
little bit too difficult and probably
before some of some of you but I think
in general this problem just like very
important but notoriously hard even
classically and I don't think like
classically people have a good
information about how we are going to
improve like the total cost here
I don't know
other questions yes like somebody asked
about what to measure that like in
principle you can imagine you could
instead of integrating the just you know
unit function you can integrate smother
function and I guess if the function is
convex then yet convex integrals also
using the same I do yes yes I think that
is a very good point about like adapt
basically about improvement on the
integral I think in general our
algorithm can be directly adapted to
give integrals for low concave functions
I think your honor for low concave
function is just like if you take a log
it's a it's a concave function I think
that the main merit is that basically
the financial function is well the most
important low concave function and
basically make a carson tactician than
everything worked through but i guess
your observations is probably also a
very nice observation of
yes we TVA expect the standard simplex
to be like a very very bad example for
the classical algorithm because kind of
like the conditioning you mentioned is
like s virus it can be but at the same
time I expected like maybe it is a
particularly easy set for quantum
algorithm if you look at the like to see
instances like simply sees and all the
two methods compare a well that's
actually a very good question I think in
general are very important like a line
of classical works for a volume
estimation this is really very general
about convex body but for instance what
if I tell you me information say what if
like the convex body is known to be a
polytope and whether can you give a
faster classical algorithm for the
estimation the answer is yes so actually
a very important open question on this
line is specifically about the example
of the polytope
so for polytope you see is just like a
linear programming here and I think the
main question here is that whether we
can adapt some of the technique here to
maybe some of the HSL type of algorithms
like in general frames like and worse
framework for singular value
transformation because actually you see
classically they're actually a gap about
like between like linear algebra so the
linear system to the corresponding
optimization problem and in particular
like like volume estimation unpalatable
is also a very important or such kind of
problems and maybe we can try to utilize
more structure but this is definitely a
very good question and also I think
there's some of the future works that
you want to explore in the future in
other questions
okay so I think this is one part of the
talk and I think probably because of
time limitation maybe let me also ask
ash about the next part of the of the
problem yeah yeah sorry yeah I think oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah sure sure I
think also for this part because like
this is probably is this an older result
that actually appeared in 2018 so I
think the point is that after having a
quantum algorithm on convex bodies maybe
you also want to in general because this
is really a session for come back to
meditation what if like I just give you
a convex function and you corresponding
list of the collectivization problem and
here the Oracle that compared to the
classical counterpart is going to be
evaluation Oracle we use a unitary
mapped as the x0 to the state XFX
I like to go here is as a destination as
this and actually this is a very well
studied classical problem and the state
of the art in the classical side is due
to listed formula having a quadratic
number of classical queries and runs in
cubic time so the main result actually
achieved by us and also a uni pendent
work whatever a proton killing algorithm
here in Tawaf that basically we for the
commercialization problem we can give a
quantum algorithm for post the
membership or record evaluation oracle
only using linear number of quantum
queries and we can show corresponding a
courtesan quantum lower bound and
furthermore like the additional
arithmetic complexity of our quantum
algorithm is similar to the classical
counterpart so what is the the outcome
for this so this is actually the first
non-trivial quantum upper bound on this
very general commercialization problem
and also it also similar to the world
investigation problem shows an
impossibility of the generic
quantum speed-up for coming from as
asian and actually the speed-up is the
most out polynomial so maybe let me just
quickly go through the rest of my talk
but I think the strategy here is that in
general you can reduce the
collectivization problem to like a
collectivization problem with a very
general convex function I consider a
corresponding like I fansite and
basically it can be reduces to an plus 1
dimensional akha maximization problem
but the corresponding function is linear
so having this kind of idea and I think
the nice thing that we are going to it
is going to be considered as two
different articles where for the
optimization problem Oracle you just
solve the problem but for the separation
Oracle you are going to construct a
separation if you have a point naught
inside
buddy you are supposed to construct a
separation hyperplane between this point
not inside a convex body and that
collects body per se so classical the
the Lisa from hell at work make a very
important contribution that the
reduction from the separation article to
the membership Eric only takes linear
cost whereas quantumly we can show that
this reduction only takes a poly
logarithmic cost and actually this is
going to be achieved by I think the idea
is going to consider a corresponding
function because in general if you let
me just draw that should be quicker than
saying yeah yeah yeah definitely there's
no fee yeah so if you have a point
outside a convex body and you don't you
kiss there the separation article a very
natural rate house you know the original
point inside the convex body you just
can see your dress can line this segment
and basically you're considered because
you have the membership Oracle you
roughly know the boundary of the convex
body and you just call this distance
function to be the height function here
and I think it suffices that you can
take the sub gradient because like in
general the convex body might not be
smooth so it probably is not does not
have a gradient but has a sub gradient
that basically can sub gradient is going
to be tangent to the convex body and
actually it is going to be giving a good
separation Oracle and this is actually
going to be given by up by Jordans
algorithm actually which is a clever way
to use the quantum Fourier transform
okay so maybe I think let's just very
quickly summarize so the conclusion here
is that we gave to quantum algorithms on
convex bodies so the first algorithm is
for a volume estimation of convex bodies
which actually we have a corresponding
quantum speed-up and also
sure sure yes
and also we very very briefly talk about
the quantum algorithms convex bodies
like in collectivization swimming this
are very general problems so let me list
a few or open questions so first so
first can we apply our simulation
framework to some other problems such as
partition function estimation maybe also
can be like in China or maybe go like
like we are out of the session I think
this session mainly talk about
characterization but maybe also of
interest to talk about non
characterization problems and at last I
think can we actually prove better
quantum lower bounds I think for both
problems like the current quantum is
related really bad I think we want to
really improve ourselves
thanks for yes yes I think speaking of
partition function this is really larger
topic like party - function of what I
think they basically the Montoneros
working hard on waste work they
basically talk about function is defined
long ago this great space but in general
there may be some and also I think like
the districts of a certain ecology no
one to the end but in general if you
consider a lot of physical system there
may be some other kind of partition
function that maybe you also want to
estimate I think like to it to be more
like electron or for instance like a lot
of SDP algorithms I think the keep state
can also be regarded as a certain kind
of partition function because they have
this kind of trace another trace in the
denominator of the definition of the
keep state so there are definitely a lot
of different things to to explore but
yes I think for those speaking of the
hard ways were actually we have some of
similarities in the technical details of
their work but I think it is also a very
nice one but I think there are
definitely more things to explore along
this line of research
[Applause]